[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRETT KUPREL: I'm Brett Kuprel.
I'd like to tell you
about some of the work
we're doing at Stanford on skin
cancer image classification.
This project has
been a collaboration
between the Artificial
Intelligence
Lab and the medical school.
So, let me warm
up with some facts
to motivate the
threat of skin cancer.
It's the most common cancer
in the United States.
One in five Americans
will develop skin cancer
at some point in their lifetime.
And in 2017, it's
estimated that there
will be 87,000 new
cases of melanoma, which
is the deadliest
form of skin cancer,
and almost 10,000
deaths from it.
Fortunately, there is
good news, there's hope.
The survival rate
for melanoma is 98%
if you can detect it early on.
Also, by 2020, it's
estimated that there
will be $6.1 billion smart
phones in circulation globally.
So, this collaboration
began a couple of years
ago when a dermatologist
at Stanford
saw the recent breakthroughs
in computer vision.
And he e-mailed the director
of the Artificial Intelligence
Lab.
And he said, if your program can
differentiate between hundreds
of dog breeds, I believe it
can make a great contribution
to dermatology.
So, the first step to
making a contribution
is acquiring a data set.
So, we have acquired a data set
of almost 130,000 images spread
out over 2000 diseases.
We worked with
the medical school
to clean it up and put it into
this nice taxonomy, a subset
of which is shown here.
So, in this taxonomy, you can
see green nodes and red nodes.
Green is safe, red is
dangerous, black is deadly.
And there's also
some orange nodes,
which could go either way.
It's not clearly a binary task.
So, on the next
couple of slides I'll
show some benign and
malignant lesions.
So here's some
Here's some benign lesions.
So, you can kind of see
flipping, back and forth,
a visual distinction.
But there's also
some lesions that
are very similar between the
two, which I highlighted green,
for instance.
OK, so now we have a data
set, next up is to train it.
We find that training
on finer classes
results in better performance.
So, if you consider
the figures shown,
if we train on the green nodes,
we actually train on more--
like 700 of them--
but just, imagine
we trained on the green ones.
At inference time, we
would sum the probabilities
up the tree to the red nodes,
the classes of interest.
And then further, if we're
interested in a binary task
of distinguishing malignant
melanoma from its binary
look alike--
from its benign look alike,
melanistic benign lesions,
we would renormalize the
probability sum to 1.
And this is consistent
with Bayes' rule condition
on the information,
that the disease
is one of two things, not one
of all the nine red nodes.
So, we found that we got the
best performance by fine-tuning
an [INAUDIBLE] pretrain model.
We tried a few
different architectures.
We train with AlexNet, VGG
Inception, versions one
and three.
We found Inception version
three worked the best.
We also tried feeding with a
spatial transformer network,
because many of our images have
lesions taken from far away.
We didn't find
improved performance,
and using Occam's Razor,
we just didn't use it.
So, the next step is evaluation.
We used two metrics to
compare with dermatologists--
sensitivity, which is known
as the true positive rate,
and specificity, known as
the true negative rate.
So, we show the doctors--
dermatologists-- a bunch of
images of benign and malignant
lesions.
We can then calculate
their sensitivity
as the percent of
malignant lesions
they were shown that they
ordered a biopsy for.
Similarly, the specificity is
the percent of benign lesions
they were shown that they
did not order a biopsy for.
And if they ordered
a biopsy, it goes
to a pathologist, which results
in a near-perfect diagnosis.
And for a network, we
actually, for a classifier,
we output a malignant
probability.
So, imagine we fed the
same images through,
and we got the
probabilities as shown.
Then the sensitivity
would be the percent
of malignant lesions that falls
to the right of some chosen
threshold.
Similarly, the specificity would
be the percent benign lesions
that lie to the left
of the threshold.
And in this
particular threshold,
it would be a
sensitive classifier,
because almost all
malignant lesions lie
to the right of the threshold.
And we can vary this
threshold to get
a whole range of sensitivity
and specificity pairs.
So, doing that, we
get these results
on three different tasks.
So, the first task is the most
prevalent type of skin cancer.
Second task is the
most dangerous type
of skin cancer versus
its look alike.
And the third task is the
same as the second task,
except it's using
dermoscopy images, which
are taken with a dermoscope.
It's a special device that
shines polarized light
at the lesion to expose
underlying layers of tissue.
And you might think that
dermoscopy is harder,
but, no, it's just a completely
different set of lesions.
And we also see that
the dermatologists don't
do as well in that data set.
So, let's see how the
dermatologists do.
So, this is the most
important slide.
We can see, for one, the line is
more jaggedy than the previous,
and that's because this is
a subset of our test set.
Dermatologists have
important things to do.
They can't just classify
thousands of images.
We can do it really fast.
Another thing you
notice is dermatologists
are actually widely varied
in their performance.
Anyway, from these
plots, we conclude
that we have achieved
dermatologist level performance
at skin lesion image
classification of skin cancer.
So, here's some confusion
matrices on a nine way
classification task.
It's interesting to look at
these to see the similarity.
One thing you might
notice is that we often
mispredict inflammatory.
It's such a broad category.
Another thing you can notice
is that dermatologists
will err on the side of guessing
a benign lesion is malignant
than the malignant
lesion is benign.
Because that would
be a deadly mistake.
And you can see
that from this box.
OK, so I brought a demo
of this classifier.
So this one-- I can't
actually read the text, but--
Yeah, you can see it's
malignant pigmented.
Let's do a couple of these.
This one's epidermal malignant.
There, that's probably good.
Don't want to embarrass myself.
So, I just want to say I'm
honored at how well received
our work has been.
It's remarkable that Andre
and I didn't know anything
about dermatology
going into this,
and I think that's kind of
the spirit of deep learning.
You can just get a
large enough data set
and feed it through Google's
latest image classifier.
Fine tune it, let them do all
the hard work, take the credit.
And it's just a really amazing
time to be an AI researcher,
as evidenced by three
covers of "Nature" dedicated
to breakthroughs in artificial
intelligence, two of them
here at Google.
I just wanted to comment a
little bit on the future of AI
applied to dermatology.
And I think this could also
apply to other skin diseases.
But there will be increased
access, because a lot of people
might have access to
a smartphone who don't
have access to a dermatologist.
Also, it will be more convenient
to classify your lesion,
and because it's
more convenient,
it will hopefully lead
to earlier detection.
And the survival
rate is much better
when you detect it early.
Thank you.